ja die bauern sind verzweifelt es ist
handelt sich dabei um ihren
lebensunterhalt den sie verdienen die
märz zucht ist in dänemark eine ein
großer industriezweig ist und 500
millionen euro die jährlich exportiert
werden und es gibt fast 2000 farmen ja
und die bauern müssen jetzt diese tiere
töten und gehen auch davon aus dass nach
dieser tötung diese zucht nie wieder auf
die beine kommen wird insofern können
sich gegner der pelztier zuchtfreunden
es wird wohl keine pelz tierzucht mehr
in dänemark danach geben
die regierung möchte den bauern auch
entschädigung zahlen sie möchte auch
subventionen zahlen um diesen bauern
andere wirtschaftszweige zu ermöglichen
ja und die tiere mussten ja alle getötet
werden weil das corona virus mutiert ist
auf den tieren
sag uns müssen wir jetzt hier in europa
vor diesen mutierten virus angst haben
oder wie verhält sich das es sieht so
aus dass die dänische regierung große
sorgen hat dass dieses mutierte virus
sich in europa verbreiten könnte denn
das könnte bedeuten dass dieser
impfstoff der jetzt ja gerade überall
gefeiert wird nicht mehr effektiv sein
würde denn es gibt zwölf fälle von
menschen die dieses mutierte virus
bekommen haben und es hat sich gezeigt
dass diese menschen weniger sensitive
gegen antikörper sind das heißt also
dass ein impfstoff weniger effektiv sein
könnte und deswegen will die rag
dänische regierung alles versuchen um zu
verhindern dass dieses virus von
nordjütland auf das dänische land und
dann auch nach europa kommen könnte
denn das könnte eine katastrophe sein es
gibt auch experten die sagen das ist
alles gar nicht so schlimm dass
womöglich dieses virus in menschen schon
gar nicht mehr jetzt vorkommen würde
aber man will das sicher gehen mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren